hello everyone
and welcome to rational science the only
site on the internet that does science
and physics
you might say is that true why do you
claim make that
claim that outrageous claim well we're
the only ones because
everybody else every single buddy else
uh
does particles and concepts they move
concepts around
and that's irrational and particles well
you cannot explain a single phenomenon
of mother nature's
with particles rationally so uh we're
different because we have
elegated entities we're saying that all
atoms in the universe
are physically interconnected and
if you tune in here every week you'll
get an idea of
you know some of the things that we
propose in exchange for what you hear
out
and see out there and
yeah we have a different site we also
redefine what science is
science is not the study of anything
you don't study in science anybody can
study and not
understand or be able to explain no
science is
explanation and we've also created
a foundation for the discipline
known as physics okay we have
defined the words necessary to do
physics to do
explanations of physics physical
interpretations
and no one has ever done that in 10 000
years
okay and so yeah our site is a little
different than all the rust out there
okay what are we going to talk about
today well we're
we're going to talk a little bit about
particles
we've been talking about uh for the last
couple weeks
about pseudo particles and quasi
particles and today we're going to
continue in that
line of reasoning if we can call that
reasoning
here's uh what we've been doing just a
little summary to bring
people up to speed who have not tuned in
in the last couple weeks
we've done quasis and pseudo particles
and whether those those are
emergent properties in other words
they're not
particles at all quantum calls them
particles i don't know why they use the
word particle if they're not particles
their emergent property and what it is
actually is
equations that describe collective
phenomena
uh vibrations of many molecules or atoms
or electrons or whatever
and so they look at that effect that
phenomenon of the vibration
and they call that whole vibration a
particle
and they give them names like here you
have one we talked about the other day
the phonon okay uh no it's not
like the phone hello hello no phone
is a collective excitation of atoms
forming a crystal lattice
okay and there you see an example uh
these are different phonons the
different vibrations one vibrates that
back and forth the other one
front to back and whatever all these are
different kinds of
phonons they call them phonons just the
whole
shebang the whole vibration that's known
as a particle
and it's described mathematically and
they call that equation or that
solution they call that a phonon
okay and then they go one step further
and they start moving the
phonon around remember they can
accelerate these things
and before that we talked about the
instant on and what is the incentive
it's the
god particle it's not the higgs which
was uh presented as the um
god particle now this is the real god
part why
because the incident gave uh
origin to the universe and it
never appeared it was already there but
even that's
wrong to think of it that way the way
it's uh done as you can see at the
bottom of the instant on it's got a
circle
these circles okay and those circles
represent space
and time so what happens and again this
is all from a mathematical point of view
don't try to visualize don't try to make
sense of it
it's just math okay mathematics
equations that's all it is and what
they're saying is
space and time are wound around it as a
circle
and since the circle has no beginning
and no end
neither the space and time
that's their logic if you call that
logic that's their rationality
okay and today we have a special kind of
particle
okay and it's also quasi
i call them quasis because they're a
little crazy you know
quasis okay and these are known as
charge carriers and you say
what the hell is a charge carrier okay
so let's see if i can illustrate this
for you here's a little illustration
of what a charge carrier might look like
okay
so please focus see if you can
understand what a charge carrier is okay
here it goes
those are charge carriers their lands
going from one place to another and you
can see they're carrying their charges
uh little leaves i guess okay and this
is more or less the
notion of a charge carrier uh the
problem comes when
these people say well we have uh
chart carriers that go the other way and
have a different charge
those green ones that you just saw well
we'll call them negative charges how's
that
so they were carrying negative charges
now we haven't come the other way and i
guess
i don't know the ants are white
and the leaves are red i mean is that
what a
opposite charge carrier is okay and so
here you have them i guess that's what
they're saying is that what a charge
carrier is
the other one was negative this guy's a
positive charge carrier
and now you you got it wrong uh the
charge carrier that we're going to talk
about today
looks more like this okay
see if we can get it up there see there
there is no ant okay
and whether there's a leaf a charge that
they're carrying
well that's up for debate okay but for
sure there's no
ant okay and so the question is
what do you mean carrier i thought a
carrier was like an ant that carries a
leaf
and you can say the leaf is positive
okay we'll
we'll let it go we'll call it posit and
the other guy comes in the other
direction we'll call it negative
but here we're talking about charge
which is a concept first of all
but forget about that there's no ant
if you have the leaf if anything if
we're going to talk
charge we're going to equate charge with
a physical object and say
that's what they're carrying fine but
there's no ant
carrying the leaf no ant carrying the
charge
so what do you mean charge carrier okay
and here's a definition of what a charge
carrier is okay so that you can
follow my presentation of their
theory okay this is not my theory by the
way i can only present what they're
trying to say
uh in physical terms okay
and this is their definition of a charge
carrier
charge carry a quasi it's another one of
those quasis
okay which is a particle that is free to
move
carrying an electric charge it's going
to carry you know over its head like the
little ants it's going to carry an
electric
charge okay especially the particles
that carry electric charges
in electrical conductors so you know
electricity it gives you a shock and
does a little fancy things like turn
your light on
they're gonna say those are charge
carriers
okay and okay what what are the
examples well the electrons ions and
holes well
an electron you know is a little bead we
all understand more or less that i mean
they always represent it with a little
ball you know these balls
going across okay so that's
a flow of electron beads we we
understand the mechanism okay
uh ions same uh that's the atom without
the electron okay so those move those
are positive
uh protons okay moving along okay
usually by some kind of magnetic
um you know uh
mechanism where they're accelerated
usually along a beam line and i've done
that kind of work for
many years and then holes
what do they mean you're going to
accelerate a whole what the hell are you
talking about
what is this so this is the one that i'm
interested in the holes
okay what are we accelerating here uh
says in a conducting medium okay
an electric field whatever that is
there's you know
we don't know what a field is nobody
knows just a bunch of numbers around a
central point they get weaker and weaker
as you go farther away like
gravitational field it gets weaker
farther away from the center of gravity
uh the electric field
same thing gets weaker and so on
magnetism okay
so electric field is just a bunch of
numbers vectors that's all it is
magnitude and direction can exert force
i don't know a force i don't know how
you can exert any force with a field
because the field is just a bunch of
numbers
and numbers don't usually exert forces
again like i said at the beginning
we don't move concepts in physics okay
so you got to translate this into
physics somehow you want to give a
physical interpretation
otherwise to say that a field
accelerates or exerts a force
so far you've said nothing you said love
excel uh exerts all
uh an intelligence that's all you said
okay there's nothing there so far
nothing to put my sink my teeth into
okay
uh exerts a force on these free
particles okay see now
they forget about what a quasi is what
what
these charge carriers now they turn
suddenly into particles okay
now they're going to talk about
particles and you're going to visualize
always some kind of bead that goes
through there okay but it's when we get
to the hole
the holes that's when we're gonna run
into a little bit of trouble because
there's gonna be no ant
carrying its leaf okay so that's that's
the point here okay
uh except supports that these uh
particles causing a net motion of the
particles through the medium okay
this is what constitutes an electric
current
so when you get a zap okay like you
touch a live wire
okay they're saying that's caused by
particles and
as we're going to see today some of
those particles are
holes and the holes are the
leaf without the ant underneath
in conducting media particles serve to
carry
charge i don't know how you can carry
charge because
uh you know what what the hell is uh
charge
and so let's look at a definition of
charge so that
we can cover that base as well okay
before we move on here's charge
okay very simple electric charge the
property
it's a property it's not a thing it's a
property it's like
an adjective it's a qualifier
okay it's a modifier a property of
matter
that causes it to experience a force
okay so so here's a piece of matter
whatever you might think of it uh maybe
an atom
and it's this is going to be a property
of that particle
and the property is going to experience
a force
when placed in an electromagnetic field
and there you have a little picture of
what they're referring to
and again they put particles or little
beads there one positive one
negative and you're going to look at
that and say okay i know what they're
talking about they're talking about
little
particles you know little grains of sand
or
or dust particles or some little ball
some little bead
and that's not what they're talking
about at all they're going to be talking
about fields and properties of fields
and
forces they're going to be talking about
a lot of stuff that has nothing to do
with physics
we don't have a physical interpretation
from any of this okay
so just keep that in mind it's going to
be all abstract
it's all going to be mathematical
concepts which the
mathematical physicists that's what
they're called
are going to introduce into physics as
if they were objects
i hope you can follow okay
okay so we've got a charge and a charged
carrier they're carrying charges on the
backs of their
on their backs or over their heads like
the little ants there
okay here's a typical circuit okay
and those red little balls those are
supposedly the
electron beads and i haven't drawn the
uh
atoms i just drew the beads there's a
little bit of reason for that you know
people have
forgotten uh what electricity used to be
which was you know electrons going from
atom to atom from valence band to
valence band and you know just moving
along for whatever reason
okay they're incited they're
they're uh forced to move out
by something called the voltage which is
defined as a difference in potential
that's all it is
uh so far we know we have no idea what
physical
object compels the electron b to jump
from one valence
from the valence band of one atom to the
valence band of another atom and this is
what they're saying is electricity
but okay we get rid of the atom we're
going to do with little beads there the
electron beads
and what happens is when you close the
circuit okay you have a power supply
when you close a circuit
okay the beads begin to roll around and
since
they're alleged to be negative whatever
that means in physical terms
uh the negative beads go to the positive
terminal
of the battery or the power supply
whatever you got there
so okay we understand the mechanism
we're understanding what they're saying
they're saying look there's these beads
they go around
and we're going to call that electricity
if you put your hand on the live wire
those beads will go right through you
and you know make you tremble i guess
you know i never touched
the live wire myself so i can't tell you
that experience okay um
why do i make a point of this thing
about
the electron beads well because see
classical mechanics used to do it with
atoms
what quantum has done quantum mechanics
has gotten rid of the atom
and it does it exclusively with the
electron beams there is
no atom necessary for electrical
conduction
in quantum mechanics it's just the flow
of beads they talk about
current being the flow of beads of
electrons and so we don't need the atom
they suggest or insinuate that you just
have electrons flowing
okay like if you don't need any matter
no atoms in there all you need is just
the electron if you can call that matter
okay so it's just the flow of beads
and just for reference i'm going to
compare it against our model
okay just so you're aware okay this is
our model
and that's the um the torsion
of a bunch of atoms which are bound to
each other
in other words they're all merged and so
the whole serpentine as we call it
spins in situ okay that's electricity
in other words you cannot do electricity
without
atoms that's the point okay that's the
point i'm trying to make
and you can see there's different the
different models you know you can see
the
model from classical mechanics has this
it's not even classical because it was a
turn of the century but we can call it
classical in the sense that
we have an atom at least and we have an
electron electron
was discovered or you could say
discovered
at the end of the 19th century so i'm
gonna refer that to that
as the classical model even though it's
a quantum model
really okay but the new version is
without the atom
and we're saying you can't do
electricity without atoms
okay and our our electricity
is the the uh spinning in situ
of electro atoms
that are merged one with one with the
other so it
forms this long chain which we're going
to call serpentine and it spins in situ
okay and yeah you know i've worked with
vacuum many years i can tell you one
thing
from experience and you don't have to
take my word for you can go to any
person who works at the vacuum
any person okay i'm putting my hand
in the fire for this you can go to any
person who works with vacuum and
electricity inside vacuum chambers
okay and once you pump it down
to minus seven minus eight minus nine
torr
and just keep going at some point
believe me
you will not get any electricity there
will not be
any electron beads flowing through that
empty space
and you say why would that be so if now
you don't have
any resistance before you had all these
atoms in the way
all this gas that you had in there now
you remove all that water
all that air all those gases that
residual gases you might have in there
you might even have back streaming
from the pumps or whatever you can
remove everything you have a
perfect vacuum in there the electrons
that go through the
circuit now have freedom
you know a mean free path should have
increased
exponentially you have no resistance to
the electron flow you should have
electricity flowing there like crazy
and it's the other way around once you
get into the minus seven minus eight
torr range
uh there is no electricity flowing
you might have some arcing here and
there i don't know arcing is just a
little boat
that zeus sends into your chamber and
that's it but it's not going to be a
continuous current you can't do it
it's simply impossible so no electricity
is not
the flow of electron beads without atoms
which is the quantum version of today
which is what people talk about and
that's what they write they just talk
about the electron flow they forget
about the rest of the atom
okay and that's where the danger comes
in now you need atoms
you can't do electricity without atoms
sorry
okay um uh here's uh
you know but we can all understand the
uh
flow of electron beads
but that's that's not what you have what
you have today is
also an a step on top of that you need
to explain
uh the positive current as well
okay and i'll show you why in a minute
okay but you need to explain to
the positive current what do you mean
positive current i thought the
current was always negative because it's
always electron beads that flow from
you know the uh cathode to the n it goes
to the
positive terminal right well no this is
the version i'm going to show you in a
second here
this is the version of holes
okay and so what you have is the holes
are flowing
from left to right and they go to the
negative pole they go to the cathode
and those are true holes just absence of
electrons that's what you're staring at
the electrons are allegedly flowing
towards the left towards the positive
pole
and when an electron moves from one atom
to the one to the left
the hole has moved to the right in other
words
the absence of an electron has moved to
the right
they're going to call that absence of an
electron
they're going to call that a positive
hole
okay so we have electron negative
electron
beads going to the left and you have
positive
holes going to the right okay
and yeah we can get rid of the electron
all together i guess we can just do this
with holes we can probably even get rid
of the atom those are silicon atoms by
the way
there's a reason for that typically it's
in semiconductors the business i worked
in
uh where all this is used
okay so what they have is silicon
silicon has
four uh electrons in its outer shell
okay and with four other atoms
uh silicon atoms nearby they fill the
outer uh valence band with eight
electrons so they're satisfied they
don't need anything else
but if you put in there if you happen to
what we call implant okay we're gonna
implant an atom in there that is either
phosphorus or
boron if you put boron what you have is
three electrons in the outer shell and
so it's missing an
electron and that electron is going to
cause electron flows
inside that uh that lattice in other
words that
crystal lattice what you're going to
have is electrons from one
silicon moved to that electron that's
missing
in the boron and vice versa if you put
phosphorus in there phosphorus has five
electrons in this outer shell and it's
going to be a donor it's going to donate
one of its electrons which it has
no idea what it's going to do with it
and that electron is going to be
free to flow in the opposite direction
of holes
so we're going to have holes moving in
one direction and we're going to have
electron beads
negative electron beads in the other
direction holes are positive
electrons are negative okay so this is
the notion that uh
we have in in semiconductors uh
processing we have
holes and electrons
what is a hole it's the absence of an
electron in a valence
band in the outer shell okay of an atom
okay very um
very scary because this is what you're
staring at here okay
you ever see bugs bunny uh he moves the
hole around
and these guys are gonna move a hole
through the desert okay they're gonna
move the
rabbit hole so to speak okay
very scary stuff okay that's what
they're proposing they're proposing the
whole moves
here's a another uh an analogy of what
they're talking about
you heard of the puzzle of the
16 squares okay and you move the
electron to the right we're going to
call these squares electrons okay
and if i'm going to i got to do this
right i moved it to the uh
left to the left and i created a hole to
the right and if i move
the next one now let's see if i can do
this
by looking at i move that one over there
where did the hole move well the whole
move to the left again
okay and i can continue doing that okay
here's and here it is again
i can get it okay and you can see the
hole is always moving to the left
and what they're saying is the electron
is a little square
and the hole is the hole there let's see
here
the absence of an electron okay so you
can see
there's a flow of holes and they're
going to call that
a current they're going to say it's a
like a positive current
okay so this is how they're going to do
this okay just keep in mind what we're
doing here we're saying that it's the
absence of an electron and as the
electron creates an
absence of an electron in the previous
atom what filled that is
a hole in other words what you would be
seeing on a screen is electrons going
one way and a hole's going the other way
that that's the notion okay
why do we need this well we need this
for example in
semiconductor processing you need this
because uh
you know i took a course very tough
course called uh
device physics and they go through a lot
of uh
calculations it's just a merger on the
math you got a lot of
equations you have calculus etc that you
have to apply
and what you're calculating is how many
carriers how many carriers
you have to have to create certain
electrical effects
okay that's in a nutshell what you're
doing and
what are carriers well you have
one chunk of
matter silicon to make it simple
so they have gallium arsenide they have
some other stuff but
let's assume we have silicon and again
you're going to
dope that silicon in one case with
phosphorus and you're going to have it
negatively doped because it's got an
extra electron in its outer shell
and the other one you're going to do
with boron which has one few
few one it has only three electrons in
this outer cell
so it's going to be it's going to be an
acceptor type of atom
and so you have this material with
phosphorus
donor negative and you have this other
material with boron positive
okay what happens when you put them
together
well as soon as you merge them you
create what is known as a depletion
zone in between there's a junction there
and that
junction is known as the depletion zone
why because what happens is the
electrons get filled in all that region
okay so you have
neutralized all those atoms at a certain
distance from the junction
okay and it looks more or less like this
let's see if i can show you this
okay and here you see it uh what you
have
is a p-type region that's the boron and
you have the n-type region that's the
phosphorus okay
as soon as you touch those two pieces
those two chunks of matter
what you create is that depletion region
at the bottom
and what is that well you have a
negative ion from a filled
hole and you have a positive ion from a
remove
hole okay so you have this region that
is
kind of neutralized okay and the only
way
you can get past that barrier is
applying a voltage to the ends
okay and and
at some point you have to have strong
enough voltage to create a current to go
through that
okay that's how they can regulate um
you know how a diode or how an
interfacing a transistor works okay
that's essentially how these
things work in general terms uh
uh you know from from an electrical
point of view
what what you have is a uh a little
thing that has a little
piece of matter on one side you have
phosphorus and the other one have
uh boron boron is positive phosphorus is
negative you put them together you
create a depletion zone
and that creates sort of like a barrier
and the only way you can overcome that
barrier is by applying
a current to the terminals right
voltage and you have current flowing
through that depletion
region as soon as it's high enough okay
as soon as the voltage is
high enough okay and you can control
that they have what's called a bipolar
transistor
where you control the guy in the center
okay also
moss metal oxide semiconductor or you
control the guy in the center
and by controlling the voltage in the
guy in the center you can control how
much flow there is
you know from right to left for example
okay
but that's why they needed to create
this whole thing because
they had to explain how you create a
depletion region
okay the depletion region all you have
is really
assuming we there are such a thing as
electron beads
well it gets saturated that whole region
you know kind of
blends in and turns into this neutral
region that you have to overcome with
uh voltage applied to the ends to the
terminals
so we create the hole and we had the
quantum mechanics had to invent the hole
and the hole is actually the absence of
matter
if you want to consider an electron a
negative electron beat a
piece of matter well the hole is an
absence of matter
that's what it is and because the other
guy's negative they put this one as
positive
so one question you should ask yourself
is whether a positive whole
right is attracted by a positive proton
i mean you have this boron atom you have
this phosphorus atom right
and they have protons in you know the
planetary atom which they still use in
quantum
they have these protons in the center of
the uh in the nucleus in the center of
the atom
and you have this hole if the hole is
positive right because
you remove the electron and that's what
a hole is the absence of an electron
and they call that a positive particle
quasi particle
pseudo particle is that pseudo
quasi-attracted positive pseudo
attracted to the positive proton
you have a positive nothing and
you have a positive something in the
center of the atom okay
is that attracted or repelled should be
repelled right
you would think but you can't repel
nothing and i guess you can't attract
nothing either so
maybe it's a meaningless question in in
quantum mechanics okay so let me give
you
uh the notion here uh
some people say well um you know i'm
i'm suggesting that no one understands
quantum mechanics
and a lot of people criticize me and say
well bill
maybe you don't understand quantum
mechanics but everybody else does
you know you have people like feynman he
tells you in your face look
you know we don't understand here he is
he says i think i can safely say that
nobody understands quantum mechanics
do not keep asking yourself if you can
possibly avoid it but how can it be like
that
nobody knows how you can be like that
the more you know how strangely
nature behaves under the particle
hypothesis
okay the harder it is to make a model
that explains how even the simplest
phenomena
actually work so theoretical physics
mathematical physics has given up on
that
and you tell them this you show them
this you say look this is fine he's a
nobel prize
1965 no prize in physics mathematical
physics mathematics
and he's telling you they don't
understand they say well you don't
understand what he's saying
you're or you're misinterpreting what
he's saying and he goes through this uh
run around saying no no see he he tried
to say something else and he didn't
follow up on what he was saying
no he's telling you in your face that
you don't understand it that
nobody understands it uh niels bohr had
already said that
werner heisenberg you know these are the
founders of quantum mechanics
they all said the same thing nobody
understands
quantum mechanics and these people say
no they do understand or maybe they're
too modest to
to recognize it or because how can it
possibly be that they don't understand
and they invented the bomb you know for
example and we have all this technology
well again technology has nothing to do
with science
okay these are two different uh aspects
of human activity
uh developing gadgets you don't need to
understand what a field is you don't
need to understand
what light is you don't need to
understand what energy is you just
do stuff in the lab stuff that you don't
see that you can't touch
and you see certain effects and you're
going to use the effect
in some way that is good for mankind
okay
so you don't need to understand you know
the the fundamentals
of what's really going on in that secret
world invisible intangible world of
mother natures
you do not need to understand that okay
to do technology so you can invent the
bomb
without having you know the
without understanding exactly what's
going on at the atomic level
and these people explain it with
particles but when you put them against
the wall they say well we don't
understand it either
and they're telling you that they don't
understand that they tell you over and
over that they don't understand and and
the answer is well you wouldn't have
defended the bomb if you didn't
understood
okay so this is this is a problem this
is a serious problem
because people don't understand that the
mathematicians
don't understand because they cannot
explain in a rational manner
what's happening at the atomic level for
example in the case of an atomic bomb
okay and again the iranians don't have a
bomb
apparently they don't have a bomb today
and their mathematicians are just as
good as the guys in the west
so no the fact that you know a lot of
math and that you can describe
and that you know even if you knew what
happens at the atomic level
doesn't mean that you can invent the
bomb because that's done by trial and
error in a lab you do certain things
and you have to put it together you have
to create a device and that's got
nothing to do with science science is
about explaining
tell me how what a field is tell me what
energy is
and how it works that's what you need to
do you got to figure out how the
invisible and tangible world of mother
nature's
is that's what science is about and
that's what we don't have today
certainly not from quantum mechanics or
relativity or strength theory okay
okay so here's uh my summary my
conclusions
okay and this has to do with overall
quantum is
any particular um
the quasi particles especially the whole
okay
here's the summary or the conclusion
okay a hole is alleged to be a charged
carrier whatever charge carrier is what
is a charge carrier
it's labeled as a pseudo particle
is a charged carrier a particle at
all why do they use the word particle is
it to confuse you to mislead you
so that you think that you're talking
about a little bead is that the point
to give it some measure of physical
interpretation to their abstract
equations
to their fields to their waves to their
pseudo particles is that what is it's
all about
the term carrier insinuates that a hole
is carrying
and delivers an object you know a little
ant with a little leaf
you we all understand that the the ant
is delivering
it's carrying and delivering a leaf we
all understand that
okay we see the movie we we understand
but to say that a hole is a charged
carrier and carries what
charge over its head is that the
language that we're seeing here is that
what the language represents
okay so i hold this an empty slot
slot left in the valence band by an
electron beat that drifted to another
atoms
so there's a hole behind they call that
hole a something
and they put a little positive science
to distinguish it from the negative
electron which is a bead so we have a
negative bead
and a positive nothing okay in the
positive nothing's flow
that's what a hole is that's what the
quasi-pseudo particle
is a nothing that is slowing that's got
that's got charge positive charge
whatever that is
holes are let's to be positive because
they um
travel in a direction opposite to
electrons
so the electron is negative because it
goes to the left the other guy has to be
positive because it goes to the right
okay is that what positive and negative
mean
is that the same thing when we say that
a proton is positive
does it mean it goes to the right well
the electron goes to the left
okay i mean if they're positive and
negative you would think that the
that they attract each other right i
mean that's that's the
uh catechism of quantum mechanics
positive attracts negative
okay depletion layers in diodes and
transistors are
explained using the whole concept
okay so you need to in fact if you took
like device physics that you get all
these
gazillions of carriers that you have to
calculate how many carry you
need to put in there to create certain
electrical effects
and so they these are real in the sense
that uh
that's how it's taught you're taught
that you have
carriers hole carriers you know they
carry charges
and you have to count how many carriers
there are how many ants there are
how many leaves they're carrying that
that that's the kind of
mathematics you get taught in college
okay it's called quantum mechanics
and uh the physical interpretation of
quantum is irrational
and proof of that evidence you like
proven evidence
demonstration persuasion uh
go to mr feinman he'll tell you we have
no idea what we're doing
in in the lab they they can describe it
mathematically because they see
something happening and they describe
the visible stuff
mathematically and they kind of
simulate that empty space where they
can't see or touch
they simulate that with particles
and that's where they're going to apply
their equation to they say well there's
so much speed between a and b
so we're going to say that particle took
i don't know five seconds to get from a
to b
for example and so they're going to
assume it's a particle
a one-way particle and they're just
going to describe its motion
or its energy or how much force was
needed or etcetera or how much mass it
has
that's the way it's done okay are there
particles does that mean there are
particles
no there aren't particles because mr
feynman has just told you and so did mr
bohr and mr heisenberg they tell you
that don't try to visualize this don't
try to imagine it with particles
but we're going to use the word particle
anyways because a particle is just
an equation in the case of
quasi-particles more than that it's just
a uh an excitation you get excited
okay let's go with the questions and uh
comments this week we had quite a few of
them i went through a rush
private restroom somehow here's the
first one
uh okay yeah this fall has been going on
for a couple weeks
uh he says uh we're going to talk
physics there is an
actual dictionary we are using the most
popular one is
a dictionary of physics he was trying to
define the word
object which we think is crucial to
understanding physics you can't do
physics without an object
so he tried to define and he says well
you know physics
definition of object he says he got this
out of a dictionary a
scientific dictionary it says
identifiable collection of matter
and i say he didn't get it from a
scientific dictionary he got it from the
wikipedia which does exactly the same
thing
an object is an identifiable collection
of matter
so i guess though he considers the
wikipedia
scientific dictionary and
so i asked him uh he said no he got it
from somewhere else that it wasn't from
the wikipedia so i said well you know
you can put a link you know and we can
look and uh
judge objectively whether you got it
from a scientific dictionary
and he says well youtube isn't letting
me put post links
and so he doesn't have to he he could
just separate the little h from the ttps
and he can put that in there and we can
still you know we can do that you can
put the h together with a ttps
find out where he got it well he never
showed up again
but he just said uh so you have to do
your own search
you can simply google physics
definitions
so when you go out there and you can do
that you don't take my word for it
please
uh go out there and do a physics uh
definition or scientific definition of
the word object
again we can't do physics without
objects so you would think it's one of
the crucial words
that they're going to define in physics
the first thing you won't find it
in any textbook of physics on the planet
and has never been in any
textbook of physics on the planet no one
has ever defined the word object
and you can't do physics without an
object so that should make you think
that
maybe all these mathematicians are not
on the right track
and it's very simple to understand why
mathematics has nothing to do with
objects and all the so-called physics
for the last 400 years has been done by
not physicists by mathematicians
okay so it's the mathematicians who've
done phys
so-called physics and then it found a
need to define the word object because
they don't use
objects they just do equations that's
that's why you won't find a definition
in any dictionary or so-called
physics or science uh but when you look
it up
you'll find uh those two definitions
essentially you find the one in the
wikipedia which i just mentioned
a collection of matter okay and then the
other one
very popular more popular still which is
the you'll find in
actually all so-called scientific
definitions
scientific dictionaries that have the
word defined
because half of them don't and i'm going
to show you that in a second
and it says anything that is visible or
tangible and is relatively stable in
form
well the first problem is the word
anything anything is a synonym
of objects so you can't use the word
anything to define
object because a synonym is a
circular definition so anyone who uses
the word thing
or anything or something already has
bombed out
you can't use that word to define the
word object because
that's the word we're trying to define
something thing and anything
and then visible intangible they think
uh all these
people just got it from the same place
or have the same notion and that's that
an
object is that which you can touch or
see and the problem with that
first of all is that you need another
object to do the touching and seeing
which makes the definition circular
again you need two objects
to define one object you need to and you
need to carry out an experiment
in other words until the asteroid
doesn't hit the moon and touches it
we don't know if the asteroid or the
moon is an object we got to wait until
that after it really hits the moon and
then we can call the moon an object
that's the problem okay and um
here is what you'll find out there well
now here's uh
my challenge to what this fellow said
uh first there is no dictionary of
science that defines the word object
thing something
entity all those synonyms right in a
rational manner
meaning if you're going to use the word
anything or you're going to say visible
intangible
you're already bombed out okay and
collection of matter
again that's myriology and
table is not a collection of matter any
more than an elephant is in other words
collection of matter is not not a
physical object
okay so you don't say that a table is
just a bunch of particles
or an elephant is a bunch of particles
that's a collection of matter that does
not
constitute an object okay uh
what is the definition it's a limitation
placed on the use
or extent of a word okay and a rational
definition was one that can be used
consistently meaning
rationally scientifically okay and
uh there's the definition of object that
which has shape
he who doesn't like it has to be come up
with a better mouse trap
and be able to defend it it's not just
the way question of saying i copied it
from a scientific dictionary even if you
did
it doesn't matter because you got to
defend it you know anybody can copy
that's a science saying oh i got a
dictionary from
i got a word out of a dictionary what is
that
if the person who wrote it is is uh
mentally [ __ ] uh
does that make your definition rational
okay
and here are dictionaries that i checked
on the internet
okay i checked several more but i only
put six here three on the left and three
on the right
the three on the left did not define the
word object at all
okay so you won't find it in there they
don't they talk about physics and other
stuff but they didn't define the word
object
and you would think that if they're
gonna define if they're gonna talk about
physics at least they gotta have a
definition for the word object
the ones on the right they all have the
same thing they all go back to the
something and to the visible intangible
or see and touch
okay and you can see they're they're all
the same essentially
and no those definitions are
unscientific they cannot be used
consistently
they are irrational because they rely on
an experiment
and they require a second object so
there's many
many problems with all those definitions
and they're all the same essentially c
touch that's why the c touch criterion
or criteria
cannot be used to define the word object
in physics in ordinary speech that's
another
issue okay okay
along the same lines another fellow
asked
he says because we say a square is an
object why
because it does have shape okay and it's
not the notion of object that you have
in ordinary speech
people confuse the ordinary speech with
scientific languages what do you mean a
square is an object
yeah in ordinary speech that sounds
strange in physics it doesn't
because what's the definition of object
that which has shape
does a square have shape well look at
that square does it have shape
and the file says thinking of a slight
modification to your otherwise excellent
definition for object equal that
which has shape and at least one unit of
mass
okay so are we gonna uh should we weigh
the square
to determine whether it has at least one
unit of mass
is that what he's suggesting he says we
have to carry out an experiment
to determine whether it has mass or not
we got to weigh it or
however count or i don't know depending
on the definition because we have
several definitions of
mass and he would have to tell us which
one he's using what do you mean by mass
i mean
here we have uh where do we have it here
these folks say that we don't know we
have no idea what mass
is okay and our
wheeler and taylor wheeler died a couple
years ago
uh and they wrote in a book nature does
not offer us
any concept as the amount of matter so
if that's what you were taught in high
school
you got it wrong okay these people who
outrank you for sure
they say that amount of matter is not
the definition of
mass they're saying history has struck
down every proposal to define such a
term
even if we could count number of atoms
or by any other counting method try to
evaluate amount of matter
that number would not equal mass okay
and i don't want to complicate it but
when you put uh
special relativity okay into the picture
and they talk about
uh traveling at the speed near the speed
of light they say mass increases
well that sounds like weight it sounds
like pressure on a scale you know the
faster it goes the more pressure on the
scale the more you weigh is
is that what mass is relativistic mass
it's just weight so again all these
people you got to define what mass
is because there's different notions i
don't care which one you use but
whichever one you use
you're going to run an experiment and
you're going to use another object which
in this case is a scale
so no uh anything that involves motion
is not a good it's not a rational
definition for the word object
and here are all the others so that i
can save you some time in case you want
to try it okay let me put it over here
okay none of these definitions will pass
they're easily
debunked okay it can't be that which you
can see
touch hear taste smell you can't use the
senses to determine
the definition of the word object to
define the word object
you can't use the word mass okay it's
not mass it's not volume
okay can move made of parts
muriology which is uh essentially what
this fellow is saying when he's saying
mass also
you're saying one unit of mass he's
saying it's got parts
okay uh it's not that which you
visualize through time
okay the temporal parts as is known
meteorology again
uh parts of whole and temporal parts etc
uh it's not which is extended because
extension is a verb
okay so you have to extend it to find
out if it's an object etc
that you can use in a sentence you can
use the word orbit in a sentence orbit
is not a physical object orbit is a verb
for the purposes of physics it's a noun
in
ordinary speech it's not a noun in
physics you cannot talk about
uh the orbit of jupiter now in
physics we say it in reverse we say
jupiter orbits
and orbits becomes a verb okay same with
orbital by the way they say
lots of orbits make an orbital and an
orbital is a physical object
a noun no not in physics okay maybe in
religion of quantum
not in physics has color uh is 3d
and is it's got to be a standalone
object you should be able to point
to the object that you introduce in
physics it's got to be standalone it
can't be
like i always say the halo of an angel
or a field
of a magnet field is not a physical
object it doesn't stand alone
uh you can't use plasma as a physical
object there's no physical object called
plasma
plasma is a phenomenon
it's a dynamic concept known as plasma
you have to ionize the atom in fact many
of them
so plasma is not a physical object you
can't point to
to plasma because whatever is in that
frame of the film in just that frame
is not moving it's not being ionized you
need to see at least two frames to
understand
the concept plasma okay and it takes
people in the electric universe 10 years
to understand what i just said
okay so just go over it one more time
maybe you'll figure it out one of these
days
okay another fellow says
ropes don't exist i don't know what you
mean by exist
your ropes are a concept i don't know
what you mean by concepts
this is a rope what do you mean a rope
is a concept that
looks like an object it has shape so
a rope is an object here and in the land
of the clan guns on the other side of
the universe so i don't know what you
mean
what you mean by ropes is a concept
again you got to define what
existing concept is otherwise you said
absolutely nothing
okay and uh here's another fella and he
says the following he says
get this up here uh he says one big
rarity in this uh electromagnetic
rope i guess he says hypothesis is that
the thread does not go through itself
but the rope does
consider the very model for magnetism in
the hypothesis where the threads
collide to push or to pull thus creating
the effect we see in magnets okay so
he's saying that
the threads okay they hit and push each
other away or they go
i guess i pull this out a little bit
just so you can see it
what i'm saying here so if you go in
this way
the threads gazillions of threads just
pushing each other away
that's the repulsion mechanism for for
magnetism
and then when you turn the magnet 180
degrees now this one's
pulling these threads come down this way
these are going this way
so they're both going in this case i
guess in your from your point of view
it's counterclockwise yeah
and so this one comes down when this one
comes up and that's when the attraction
occurs
and that's the mechanism of attraction
and so he's saying well you know the
threads are going
uh he's saying the threads are pulling
on each other
and now the answer is no and so let's
clarify that for
him let me read the rest of it here
because
he raised an important question clearly
a single thread
of the rope is the active element there
and either cannot go
through itself or does so with some
resistance
ah resulting in the push or pull forces
yeah you said that cr that's the
critical part uh
with some resistance there is a friction
okay and let's go over that okay it's an
important
issue and i think it needs to be
clarified he also added the following
okay here let's continue with what he
said because he
he got the right issue in here the rope
seems to have no difficulty
at all in crossing itself it could be
argued that where the threat able to go
through itself it would not be able to
form the rope
since the thread would slide right
through the other one
there must either be extreme resistance
to cross or total exclusion
this begs the quest the question why
would the rope provide
for what the single thread cannot is it
another property of the single piece
object
okay very very good question i think
okay
needs to be clarified let me put it over
here
so let's see how we answer this okay
and the first thing i want to mention
here is are the
properties of the thread what we're
proposing okay so these are the
properties we're proposing for the
single thread that makes up all matter
underlies all matter
in the universe all atoms all ropes that
interconnect them are made of the same
thread there's only one thread
close blue thread in the entire universe
that's that's the notion we're proposing
as an assumption as a starting
assumption to be able to explain
later on the theories that
form what we call thread theory okay
okay so here it is
these are the properties of the thread
of the single thread
that underlies all of matter uh it
resembles the thread of macro of our
macro world
see if i have yeah i have a little
thread here tied to a little
okay that's a thread okay and so it
resembles this
okay that's what we're talking about
we're suggesting that there's
a single thread uh here's another
example maybe of that
a little i hope you can see that that's
a rubber band okay
it doesn't stretch okay so the
stretching is not
part of the properties okay it's made of
a single piece and it doesn't stretch
okay
but you can think of the thread as this
that's what it is okay
so very simple closed loop thread very
simple
as simple as you can make it that's what
it is that's what we're proposing single
thread
close loop thread okay but here are the
differences with the thread of ordinary
speech
of our everyday macro world okay it has
the shape of a macro thread
yeah it is thus an object because it has
shape
right the rubber band this rubber band
has shape
okay if it has shape to you well that's
what this thread is and so it has shape
it is an object
okay so i hope that's clear it's an
object very simple kindergarten stuff
okay
don't make it any more complicated than
it is it's just a single thread
closed loop thread so close loop
it's uh made of a single piece and this
is
the the issue that this gentleman comes
up with because we have the issue
if it's made out of a single piece uh
we can explain some things but not
others
okay according to our macro world
notions
of everyday experience okay so our
everyday experience
comes up against this why because
we don't see things going through things
in our everyday
world and it turns out that
you don't have to take my word for it uh
go to quantum mechanics and they say
that particles go through particles
and nobody questions that and you say
what do you mean particles go through
particles well i showed it the other day
uh just an example okay that
uh where is it here here you have uh
that here you have light let me get this
out for a second here
so that i can show this to you okay here
you have light
okay and here you have another light
okay two lights
and i can have these lights go through
each other in other words
you know the lights are crossing each
other
they're not interfering there are no
particles jumping
away from each other try to do that with
your um with your bathroom shower take
two bathroom showers or two hoses
okay just take two hoses at home and
have
water pouring out of them great speeds
and just cross the uh
the waters you know across the hoses the
paths of the water
and you'll see that you get splashes
everywhere the
the particles of water whatever water is
right some molecules some atoms
they they jump out of there they jump
out of that collision there is
a collision okay and
in the case of light you don't see that
and again here you have another example
gravity invisible intangible
you don't see anything below the pencil
you don't see or touch anything above
the pencil okay
and the pencil always goes to the floor
and you say well hold it it always goes
to the floor why does it go to the floor
well i think there's only two
possibilities because we only have two
forces in the universe
one is push the other one is pull it's
push or pull
okay the mathematicians invented four
forces four horses of
of the apocalypse as i call them there's
only two forces
that's all we can imagine it's either
pull or push you have the glue on and
the graviton the pull forces
and the uh what is it the weak
and the electromagnetic they're both
push forces
and uh so we have pull and push so
i don't know what other force there is
that you can imagine
and the issue is you have gravity and
when you have the earth go around the
sun
at some point it gets in the way it
eclipses
so to speak uh jupiter and some other
planets
uranus uh pluto it gets in the way
between the earth between the sun and
then this other planet right
and it doesn't cut the effect of the sun
on those if anything it adds to it but
it's not because the earth gets in the
way
between the sun and pluto that pluto
says finally
and escapes out of the solar system so
whatever gravity is it goes right
through the earth
and all the way to pluto so gravity is
invisible and intangible just like light
is
okay so we have invisible and intangible
light invisible and intangible gravity
we have to explain those properties
those are the properties of mother
nature and we don't have any such thing
in our macro world such as those
invisible
mediators that mother nature uses to do
gravity and light
am i getting through okay okay
let me say that one more time just in
case because some people maybe have not
understood
i'm saying that gravity and light are
mediated by a
physical object that which has shape
an object that is invisible and
intangible
which again destroys the definition of c
touch
for the word object okay so c touch
cannot be used because here we have an
object that has shape if it's an
object but cannot be seen or touched
okay and so that's what we have to try
to do
we have to imitate mother nature's world
father universe who will god whoever you
believe in
okay so the issue here is the following
we're going to use the thread and in
order for the thread to be an
object has to have shape i think i've
established that with a rubber band it
looks like that rubber band except it
doesn't stretch
okay make sure it doesn't stretch people
think it stretches no it doesn't
it's just made of a single piece it's
malleable
it's malleable and you can't touch it at
least not in the
macro world sense okay it doesn't have
the property of touch
that we have in our macro world whether
there is
some kind of touch uh some kind of
friction at that level
that's that's what's going to be an
issue here you know
is there a friction and can it go
through each other
well it can go through each other in a
sense much like a river can go through
or water and go through water
or air can go through air you know and
again
you know in the real world particles
exclude other particles from their
location
because they're made out of atoms
but here we're talking about something
so fundamental
that it doesn't have the property of
touch that we have in our macro world
meaning that one thread cannot exclude
another thread
from whatever location it has at that
moment in time if you could talk about
location
at that level okay so the thread goes
through a thread but this file says well
if it goes through a thread how can you
make the rope
which is a very good question okay and
believe me i thought about that a long
time uh
when i wrote my book originally okay it
was a big problem
okay so uh first let's get back to the
uh make sure we understand the
properties of the thread okay here it is
one more time
okay so we cover those and uh a closed
loop made of a single piece
it's not rigid despite that it's made of
out of a single piece
okay and you say hold it anything made
out of a single p has to be
piece has to be rigid
well keep in mind we don't have any
example in our macro
world of anything that is rigid
meaning made of a single piece
everything is made of
atoms okay and so if
everything is made of atoms we don't
have anything made out of a single piece
even the atom itself because
again well there are different versions
even but if you take the quantum version
for sure
you don't have a single piece so we
don't have single piece
especially in our macro world
and so we don't have perfect rigidity we
don't know what rigidity is
we have no way of imitating anything in
the world of rigidity
rigid does not necessarily mean made of
a single piece i mean
yeah that is a good definition for
rigidity but in mother nature's world
she's got this
thing made out of a single piece but
it's not rigid it has the properties
more
of like a rubber band of an ocean you
know water moving around
it's fluid okay we're talking again
the fundamental thing that makes
everything else okay so
let's keep the context in mind okay um
it goes through itself okay it's
invisible and intangible
especially in our macro world okay we
have no way of seeing
we don't we can't see atom we can't see
a hydrogen atom which is in the angstrom
level okay which is
uh to the minus tenth of a meter
okay so we're talking about something
you can't see
and this thing is much thinner than an
atom
if you take the diameter or even the
radius of an atom
a hydrogen atom the smallest atom this
thing is
you could say infinitesimally thinner
than that it's just something
vanishingly thin
that's why perhaps it has some of these
properties or at least those are the
ones we're going to assign to them
if we're going to explain mother
nature's world and mother nature's world
is this
intangible invisible world of objects
hopefully she does it with objects and
not with
spirits hopefully she does gravity with
some kind of object
and not with hocus pocus hopefully she
does light with some kind of object
invisible and intangible object
and not with spirits and so when you use
the word energy you're saying spirit and
when you use the word field you're using
the word ghost and when you're using the
word
uh mass or or wave
you know you're using the phantom
you're using concepts as objects
we have to identify the physical object
that
underlies light gravity magnetism etc
electricity
so you can't say well there's no object
there because then you are introducing
black magic
okay let's hope that's clear and many
threads
produce the tangibility and visibility
that this gentleman talks about
so yeah when he qualified that he uh he
essentially did the right thing
because uh he came back to rationality
and um i'm going to give you an example
now
of that one is the rutherford's back
scattering
if you look at um
you know the quantum atom they tell you
that almost all of it is empty space
just like the uh brains of the people
who created that it's almost
empty space between their ears and the
reason they thought it was empty space
is because of this
here they had the atom okay i'm going to
show you this in steps
here's the atom the quantum atom okay
you think of that
electron ball going around the proton
center
okay so that's essentially the model
that these people propose even to this
day they have this
cloud cloudy model essentially what they
have is a
perimeter or a volume and the electron
bead for some reason cannot escape that
volume
and for some reason it doesn't also fall
to the center of the atom where the
proton is
even though one is positive and the
other one is negative so
we don't know why that atom by that
electron runs around and doesn't leave
the atom or fall to the center that's
the first thing that
quantum mechanics cannot explain and if
they cannot explain their most simple
atom
they cannot explain absolutely anything
rationally and that's where we are today
okay we don't have an explanation that's
why
mr feynman tells you uh we don't
understand any of this
okay and bohr said the same thing
heisenberg as well
okay so what do we do well mr rutherford
went in there and he threw
he bombarded that with neutrons okay
essentially okay so here it is
uh see if we can show it here's the
neutron and it hits
the center of the atom in other words
proton a neutron hitting proton
and it bounced back he said it was like
throwing a cannonball or whatever
at the paper tissue and having the
cannonball bounce back that's
essentially how he
uh described what he observed and he did
not observe it what he simply saw
was the visible stuff and he did not
really see the interaction or what was
going on inside the atoms
okay he just said some of some of the um
stuff that i threw at it bounced back
that's all he could say
and from that he uh declared that the
element was mostly empty space
because what he found out was that some
of these neutrons
uh they just went right through it okay
they just went through the atom
especially
when it was thrown directly at the atom
the uh the whole uh
uh crystal lattice this thing went right
through
and so he said you know most of it most
of an atom is empty space because the
neutron just goes right through and only
when it hits the center do we have
something there and he called that
something the proton
okay so this is the train of thought
that mr rutherford
uh went through in 1919
and this is where we got the notion that
an atom is mostly
empty space okay again empty space is
what the
quantum mechanics has the mechanics
having their
between their ears okay so here's the uh
uh let's see if i can get it here
here's the uh rope version
of backscattering okay and so
we start by saying that we start by
showing the atom and the neutron okay
and the proton is on the left side you
can see the proton is a little
different than the neutron why because
it's got a region where only threads
uh are going to the center whereas in
the neutron the ropes
go right through the center so what you
the difference between these is ropes
versus threads okay what you have is
convergence of single threads and
convergence of ropes
that's the difference between a proton
and a neutron why does an atom have
charge
why does it have this thing they call
positive and negative
because that blue circle that surrounds
the proton
expands and contracts in other words it
eats
the rope and it releases uh a link of
the rope
so it goes back and forth that's the
quantum jump
that torques the rope and the rope is
light a very simple mechanism
baby stuff even a baby can understand it
whether you believe it or not is
immaterial we're
trying to explain a mechanism here so
that you understand it
and here again you have the atom in the
neutron okay so now we're going to do
this um
this uh neutral this neutron bombardment
this back scattering okay let me get it
in here
got them all the way at the bottom so
gotta raise them up here okay here you
have
neutron going right through a
three-dimensional atom
essentially uh if it hits in the center
like
center of the neutron with the center of
the atom it's going to bounce back
that's what rutherford verified
and if instead it goes through any other
part
the ropes go right through the threads
okay so again the thread can go through
the thread
uh the rope can go through the thread
and the rope can go through the rope
okay and so we we that's what we're
going to propose
and again uh rutherford just the only
way he could get around that was saying
atom is mostly empty space but then he
cannot explain why the little bead
doesn't fly out of the atom or fall into
the nucleus
and they never do explain that and
that's the only thing that quantum has
to explain
that's the only thing that has explain
in a hundred years and they cannot
explain
that because for that you need physical
objects you would have to tell me what
physical
object prevents the electron from flying
away and or
if you want it in a different way what
physical object lies between the
electron and the proton
what is that space there that empty
space if it's empty space
why does the electron fly away and so
people say well it's a field well it's a
field is a concept that's a bunch of
numbers
so you can't say it's a field because a
field is not a physical
object you got to tell me what physical
object is in there other people say it's
the ether
oh my god so you got all these bird
brains out there trying to figure out
what physical
object is between the electron and the
proton and no the ether at the ether is
a bunch of particles which is what it is
what the definition of it is unless you
can come up with something better
you cannot explain how a bunch of
particles a sandbox
holds one thing tied to the other okay
or why why doesn't it fall to the proton
because of the sandbox we can probably
understand there's a bunch of sand
in between fine why doesn't it fly away
is there sand on the outside also
of the atom so yeah you can't explain it
with a sandbox either
if that's what you propose otherwise you
got to tell me what the ether is what
the field is
what this energy is you got to identify
the physical object
okay okay and uh here's my explanation
for
the other issue that this gentleman
raised
and this is an analogy okay please take
it only as an analogy i'm trying to
explain why
one thread does not go through another
while they
form the rope if you take just a piece
of cotton
okay i just want you to understand the
concept here okay again
we're trying to figure out what mother
nature has in that invisible world okay
and so you if you take a piece of cotton
you can you can pull it you'll see that
it'll break up
uh the uh strength of that is not
very you know it's not very strong uh
there's not much resistance
to you pulling cotton apart okay
but if on the other hand you torque
the um the the cotton around itself
well uh it's much stronger okay in fact
one guy
explains that pretty much he says cotton
is made of a lot of tiny fibers
if you pull a cotton ball apart you'll
find that they are very skinny and quite
short
these fibers aren't stuck to each other
they are all individual pieces
what's holding them together is tangles
and friction
okay when you unroll and stretch a
cotton ball you start untangling the
fibers
which is why the cotton ball becomes so
fragile
when you start twisting cotton you do
two things
first the fibers get wrapped around each
other which helps to tangle them again
second as the twist gets tighter the
fibers are squished together
as they are pulled tighter and tighter
the friction between them
increases both of these things make your
thread
stronger again i'm saying this is an
analogy only to try to understand
some of what may be happening out there
you have two threads
okay why don't they cross each other why
do they form the
rope well what i say is that
right now you don't have any speed you
don't have you know there's no
motion of the thread against the thread
it just
it's like lying against that one thread
is just
lying against the other and they're
pulled outwards
okay they're pulled outwards by what
they're under tension
by every atom in the universe and so
between any two atoms
the rope is taught that's why we have
the speed of light
is a constant it's a constant because
the tension
between any two atoms is always the same
okay
what changes is the frequency for the
wavelength
the wave equation c little c
constant 300 000 kilometers per second
velocity of light
is equal to frequency times wavelength
wavelength goes up
frequency must come down frequency goes
up wavelength must come down
they're inversely proportional okay
so the tension between any two atoms on
the rope
is always the same and it's measured by
the speed of light that's why
the speed of light is constant the only
thing that changes
is uh the frequency in exchange for
the wavelength and we call that light we
call that colors
okay those are the different uh colors
that we get
in in the visible range at least okay
so what i'm saying is the threads are
just
lying against each other and being
pulled outwards
that's why they don't go through each
other that's different
that's different than when you have a
thread cross another thread or when you
have a rope cross under the rope
in the case of magnetism what you have
is many threads now you have again an
emergent property here okay an emergent
property
that one thread might have a little bit
of friction
i can't tell you that for sure that's i
i have to assume it does
it's an imperceptible friction that we
would not even be able to measure in our
world today of course not
but when you put them all these when you
put all these threads together that
friction
uh becomes greater and greater and
greater to the point that now for the
first time you have touch
you created the property of touch at
least in the sense that we have it in
our macro
world and what do we mean by that we
mean that
you have threads pushing on threads you
have gazillions of threads pushing on
gazillions of threads
and now they they don't go completely
through each other they do go through
each other but there's a friction when
they do so and that's where the push
comes in
the more threads that intervene the
harder it is to put two magnets together
and conversely you turn one magnet
around now they're both going in the
same direction
and now again you have a little friction
there the threads are going through each
other okay and that friction
increases the more threads that
intervene which is a function of
distance okay i guess you could say an
inverse function of distance the closer
they are together
more threads because more threads are
now intervening and so
now you have stronger friction stronger
pull
okay so uh both neutron bombardment or
back scattering or
any of those experiments as well as uh
magnetic attraction and repulsion show
you that threads do
go through threads and in the case of
neutral bombardment or
back scattering you have ropes going
through ropes but
in the form of an atom or a neutron
okay and again remember that
um the electron shell is made
of gazillions of threads coming from
every rope in the universe
so it's it's an um it's again an
emergent
property in other words an atom is an
emergent property in that sense
that it's made out of the thread and the
thread does not have the same property
as the atom which is macro world touch
why because there's gazillions of thread
now for the first time you have touch
until then you have only mother nature's
touch which is maybe an imperceptible
friction
okay so that's that's how touch comes
into being
in our macro world that's the proposal
that's the theory
okay uh i hope i answered to some degree
your questions uh and concerns here's
another
question comment okay a person said
an image of a single positively charged
strontium
atom held near motionless by electric
fields and
there was a picture when you look that
up and it looks like that one there
guy who won a prize for taking this
picture his name is david navinger
okay image of australium uh adam wins
national science photography prize okay
so
i just want to clarify that we look at
that we say okay they took a picture of
a strontium
atom uh yes and no
okay um you see two lines there the red
lines that i put in there in the center
uh i put those and that's two
millimeters that's the distance
between the two probes there the two
points that
were used to hold supposedly the
strontium atom in place
okay so let's uh magnify that so we can
see what we're staring at okay here's
the magnification of that
looks more or less like that and so this
is what this guy
got his prize for now if you look it up
you'll and again you see two millimeters
is the distance between the two
uh points there yeah two things that are
holding the strong champ
strontium atom in place strontium
uh has a diameter of 430 picometers
okay what does that mean well it means
that if you look at those two
millimeters
and you divide that by four four and a
half million times
you're going to get the uh diameter
of a strontium atom that's how small it
is so what you're seeing here
is not four and a half million times
you're not seeing no four and a half
millionth
uh part of two millimeters it's much
smaller than that what you're seeing
here is a reflection
and that's what the camera caught the
stronger
atom is much smaller than what you see
there much much smaller you're talking
about gazillions of times smaller
okay because again it's only 430
uh picometers that's that's the diameter
of a strontium atom okay so you would
not be able to
see one of these and so the issue here
that i'm trying to get to
is that we have never seen or taken
pictures
or imaged an atom even the biggest atom
you can imagine maybe uranium
more or less stable there compared to
the ones that come after
we've never taken a picture of any of
these atoms
in such a way that we can tell whether
it's it's got a little
electron bead going around it we don't
have that kind of
detail we'll never have that okay what
we have seen is
you know ball uh telescopic pictures
it's like
every time they take a picture it's uh
from very far away and it looks like the
moon
it looks like a ball that's what an atom
looks like like a hydrogen atom or any
of these atoms in general
they have different shapes but if you
take an atom that
has an s orbital on the outside that's
got that's a
sphere okay and it looks like the moon
so what is that sphere where do you find
it in quantum mechanics
i mean according to quantum mechanics
that's not a sphere what that is
is a little electron b that's moving
around what you're seeing is orbitals
you're seeing a bunch of orbits so why
do we see a ball
every time we see an electron i mean for
it to weave
you know a ball it would travel
much fast has to travel much faster than
light
and that is not the case an electron
does not travel much faster in light
to make the ball that you see every
second
okay so no no an atom does not have a
little bead running around it
when when they take images again uh
bird's eye images of atoms there
and again i'm talking about just to make
it simple
s orbital s orbital is always spherical
it always
encapsulates whatever's inside it so it
doesn't matter
it's always a sphere
and that's our atom that's the rope
model of the atom
a sphere okay but these people are
talking about something else they're
talking about a little b
that's going around and forming that
sphere
they're saying it's a cloud of electrons
well what cloud of electron does the
hydrogen atom have it's only got one
electron are you telling me that this
electron
is moving around faster than the speed
of light just to make the clouds so that
you can take a picture of it
that's irrational that's what quantum
mechanics proposes and it's totally
irrational
that's why mr feynman mr bohr mr
heisenberg tell you they don't
understand their own theory
okay on the other hand it's much simpler
let's bring uh
what's the name william of ocum and
here's going to tell you choose the
the most the simplest hypothesis what is
it
it is a sphere what you're staring at
what you took a picture of
is a sphere what is a sphere well it's
it's got this whole volume okay it's
it's a
shell it's a cloud it's an encapsulating
membrane that's what you took a picture
of
now we can make sense of that what is
that membrane it's made out of the
threads
now we can understand how an atom is
built it's built of threads
not through orbitals many orbits of an
electron
okay here on astronomy
uh again this is what this file said
he said and just to confirm just at the
bottom it says
i was rewarded with this particular
picture
of a small pale blue dot yeah that's all
you took that's
what what do you see there what kind of
detail do you see a little electrum ball
uh bead going around is that what you
see is that what you took
a picture of electron be moving around
gazillions of times faster than the
speed of light to make that ball
obviously that is a ball not a bunch of
orbitals
not a bunch of orbits not an electron
bead that's running around
that's how simple it is okay
so yeah uh quantum mechanics has nothing
to offer that's why they don't
understand it
this is what you got to answer okay
here's the quantum atom
you tell me what that yellow stuff is
that's all we want to know the
electron bead this is a hydrogen atom
supposedly one proton one electron
why does the electron bead fall to a
lower level and not all the way to the
center where you have the quarks
supposedly three quarks
from mr mark and uh and when does it fly
away
i mean when is an electron i mean it's
orbiting right
like if you swing a ball at the end of a
string and you let go of the string or
you cut the string well that ball will
fly away
why doesn't this ball fly away it's
rolling around like a planet
why doesn't a planet fly why doesn't
jupiter fly away
i mean what's holding it to the sun are
we gonna do this with
spirits with ghosts we're gonna say
black magic
keeps the uh uh
jupiter tied to the sun or you're just
gonna say what's gravity
yeah no kid it's gravity what is gravity
that's what you gotta tell me
not tell me that it's gravity okay
okay another issue another question
another comment here we go
another fellow says
he says you can't point to your shadow
no you can't
not in science in ordinary speech you
can say anything you can say
love moves mountains and you can get
away with that because nobody's paying
attention to
any of the details of whether you make
sense or not in physics we have to make
sense and now you
we got to find out what a shadow is what
is the shadow it's blocked light
black light is not a physical
stand-alone object what uh black light
is is a concept that's why we define it
we see shadow is black light
okay so now we know what matter what but
we have
the concept known as shadow it's not a
physical object it's a
it's a shot it's a concept because we
defined it
and you can't point to a concept and you
say well i pointed to the shadow
to that shape yeah but the shape there
is no shape because
the shape includes you the shadow starts
at your feet
your your you are part of the shadow you
can't separate the shadow from yourself
see if if we could separate the shadow
from you that would be great then we
could say it's got shape on its own
but see the shadow the feet uh like when
you put a light on you
uh the shadow goes all the way to your
feet it's stuck to your feet as soon as
you pull the shadow out we'll know if
it's an
object or not in physics not in ordinary
speech
okay and so in physics shadow is not a
standalone physical object
physics we point to objects okay and
define
concepts and that's what uh shadow is
it's concept that's why we define it
and you just follow the definitions and
i promise not to bang you in my
baseball bat
okay and uh here is just the icing on
the cake on that one
okay let's get it up here
objects we point to concepts
we define okay so that's black and white
okay it's uh on or off yes or no okay
and it's the third principle of physics
you can't point to a concept
so if you said that you can put to a
shadow and your shadow is
uh black light a concept and i don't
know what you're pointing to
maybe you're pointing to the floor you
say no it's my shadow
how can you point to something that
doesn't have shape you said it does have
shape see
it's got shape well shape is all around
and
i can't see it all around because your
feet are in the way
okay an issue on ether someone a couple
people
put posted something on ether well it
says uh the ether is not a bunch of
particles because it's
intangible pre-hydrogen matter
i don't know what all that means uh and
another fellow says
ether is particles what do you mean it's
particles
well you guys have to do is define ether
once we know what the definition of
ether
is then we'll know what you're talking
about and hopefully if you define ether
means not a physical object
because again what we do we define
concepts and we point to
objects and that's the ether okay
and it's not an object because i can't
point to that because it's moving
okay it's it's moving all around i see a
bunch of particles and you say well
which particle are you pointing to
uh to that one one that just moved
so uh no you can't point to ether you
can't point to ether because ether is
the definition of ether
it's a concept because you redefine it
it's a bunch of particles
and which particle are you pointing to
that's the object not the ether
okay so either a bunch of particles you
don't like that definition
there's your there's what you got to do
you got to define the word ether
don't tell me what it ain't everybody
likes to tell me what it ain't you said
you got it wrong bill
it's not a bunch of particles okay what
is it
please define the word ether until you
do you you
you're just spinning your wheels you
haven't said anything you gotta define
the word ether i mean if you're gonna
use it if you're to
if you're going to say that your theory
depends on the ether like maybe
ken wheeler does he says it depends on
the ether
you have the people in the uh john
chappelle
movement i call them the john chapel
uh they're etherists as well okay what
is the ether
you know when i told uh one of these
guys from the
uh john chappelle group that ether was a
bunch of particles
immediately he said no that's not what
the ether is don't tell me what it ain't
tell me what it is
you can say bill you're wrong okay was
it what's right
tell me what it is not what ain't and no
you'll never find anyone defining the
ether because as soon as they do it's
easier to
easy very easy to tear them in pieces
okay
that's why they don't define it oh i i
want them to define it so that i can
have a chance give me a chance to bop
them
here it is this is what i'll this is
what i'll use
[Applause]
my uh dough roller okay next question
next uh
comment thing uh what does this guy say
okay it's a square is an object because
you change the definition to
an object is that which i say yeah
not that i change it i circumscribed it
because that's what a definition is
it's a limitation placed on the extent
and or usage
of a word and so i define the word
object as that which has shape
okay and then we have a i think that has
shape
it's a square and if you don't like that
well you got to define the word object
very simple i mean if you can't define
the word object you haven't said
anything all you said is you don't
like my definition great uh tell us
what your definition is and maybe you
got a better definition than i do
i'm looking always looking for someone
who's got a better mousetrap or
been a bigger mousetrap than me
okay another issue comment
um fella says light doesn't slow down
through a transparent media uh
yeah it doesn't slow down see you got
the equation there velocity of light
equals frequency times wavelength
velocity your light is always 300 000
kilometers per second always no matter
what the light goes through because
light doesn't go through anything
light goes through things only in the
religion of quantum mechanics
in quantum mechanics yeah you have
one-way mechanism such as waves and
particles
waves are not physical objects waves are
just a bunch of vectors
they uh give you the idea that you're
talking about something
when they're only vectors okay they
don't have a physical object called a
wave
transverse wave or longitudinal wave or
whatever there is no
standalone object called wave wave is a
verb
okay and as such it's a dynamic concept
therefore you know
there's no such thing as one-way travel
of a wave
and the other one is the one-way travel
of particles well in the case of uh
classical mechanics we could understand
it because we're talking about
corpuscles
okay and we cannot explain uh
under that definition of that notion
uh we cannot explain um
wave phenomena okay you cannot explain
uh frequency you cannot explain
wavelength for sure with particles
and you cannot explain why the particle
goes up and down to create that
wavy motion what pulls the particle up
what is pushes the particle down
that's what you got to explain and if
you cannot explain that
i mean why would another particle follow
another one you know like one particle
goes up the other one goes right behind
it to create that sine wave
oh hold it we got a problem because you
know is it pulling it
is one particle pulling on the other
particle is that what makes the sine
wave
why does one particle follow another
particle are they tied together like in
a string
i mean we can understand this if i move
this around you say well
i see why why you know this portion
follows that portion because they're all
tied together
how do you do that with particles with
discrete particles
so yeah those two mechanisms at the top
that are the ones proposed by quantum
those are one-way mechanisms first and
that's always a big problem
particles you cannot explain classical
particles again i'm talking about here
okay
classical particles you can add explain
wave phenomena wave properties
of light and then under quantum
you know you don't even have particles
what you have is concepts
and they're moving concepts around
they're saying a wave is
or a particle is it's just a number
so they're moving numbers around
quantities amounts
it's like moving your bank account
around
[Laughter]
so now we have a physical logic we're
saying it's a rope and what we have is
torsion
okay torsion of a rope okay this is what
we
have and you know the more you torque a
rope
the smaller the links become and the
less you torque a rope
the longer the links become and you have
wet fewer
links and that's what color is and
that's why
when the light goes through a prism we
have different colors coming out
not because light is traveling at
different speeds but
because we've traded frequency in
exchange for wavelength and vice versa
that's what color is different
wavelengths
in other words link lengths under the
rope model so yeah there is no
traveling of uh light light doesn't
travel anywhere
light torques in situ and what we're
looking at is different
lengths of links that's it and that's
what gives you
the color so light always travels at the
same speed between any two atoms
it's always 300 000 kilometers per
second again that's
very close enough number
we don't need to know the exact value of
light the velocity of light like uh
michaelson spent his whole life
measuring got a novel for that
that's not science that's measurement
measurement is not science
measure science is explanation okay
observation isn't part of science
then you drop a pen to observe yeah i
dropped the pen the other day okay so
he's saying that
you let go of the pen yeah and he said
that's that's observation
and experiment isn't a part of science
then you cross
two flashlights like i did a minute ago
uh asking
what did you observe no i did not ask
what did you observe
that's what he got out of it i don't ask
that question
what we have is this this is the context
for the word observation
why we do not have observation in
science
let me put it over here on
i guess uh your left hand side my left
hand side your right hand side
okay um it says
in the religion mathematics okay observe
observation
is used as a weapon that's what it is
it's a weapon
okay and what do you mean a weapon well
observation means experiment it means
measurement
okay it means evidence proof why did you
do an experiment well because you're
going to prove to someone that
your theory is correct whatever
explanation you gave
you're gonna back it with evidence what
is evidence an experiment or an
observation
okay and what is an observation well so
far all you have is a description
so all you did is gawk until you can
explain something
you haven't said anything oh you said
yeah the car went down to him
and you say okay why did he go down the
hill oh i don't know i just
saw it i observed it going down to him
all you're doing is testifying that you
saw something you describe it but you
have no
explanation for the phenomena so that's
why it's not
observation that's the context okay um
it's got to do with perception which
means it's subjective
it's used to persuade convince the jury
okay and it's used to convert
and recruit it's only to get the jury to
believe like you do that's why we do
that's what they use observation and
experiment for
okay that's why we don't have any use
for observation in science
in science uh we say uh
and again you see the examples there of
another issue which is that
did uh stephen hawking ever observe
you know like with his eyes did he ever
observe a black hole
did rather ford ever observe the empty
space
inside an atom
this doesn't mean that they cannot make
an assumption and they say let us assume
which is what they're doing really they
said they proved it but that's their
opinion let us assume that
an atom has absolutely nothing inside it
between the proton and the electron that
is mostly empty space
then you make an assumption you you
didn't observe you just make an
assumption to
to explain your theory and you say now i
can explain this with that
with that assumption that's the way it
works in science you make an assumption
you don't have to observe and say yeah
you observed so you can't
call me a liar because i observe with my
two eyes
now that's that's not scientific in
science we say let us assume
let us assume that god exists now you
can
continue with your theory of how god
created the universe but you can't say
oh
god exists i proved it here's the
evidence the evidence is in the bible
now you can't do that in science and
science is it's uh
unfair it's an irrational okay what we
do in
science we make an assumption and so we
don't need the word observation at all
you don't because observation is what it
says they're testifying it's uh
it's saying that you're going to bring
subjectivity to your presentation you're
going to try to convince
the jury that your eyes did not fail you
with that i'll see you on sunday and
we're going to
have my son here and i'm going to open
the floor
for questions we're uh so it's gonna be
live whatever
questions you may have we're gonna try
to address them right on the spot
uh again sometimes there are too many
questions we can't address them all but
we'll try to
address as many as uh we can okay so
my son huns is going to be here and
we're going to try to
have a good show for you so get your
questions ready anything you want to
throw mud pies in our face
do it no problem we can take it we got
thick skin here
we'll see you on sunday bye bye